[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 133 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
I am Mark Mandel, and
I'm here as always
with my colleague,
Melanie Warrick.
Melanie, how are
you doing today?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm good.
How are you doing, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: I'm very well.
Very, very well.
Unfortunately, we're not in the
same place at the same time--
MELANIE WARRICK: No.
And this week, in particular,
you're in Denmark.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
When this comes out,
I'll be in Denmark.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So, Mark, who do
we have on the show this week?
MARK MANDEL: So today, we have
Brahim from the Android team
and Sachin from the Firebase
team coming to talk to us
about ML Kit.
I'm kind of excited about this.
I think-- I love these packaged
machine learning solutions.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
MARK MANDEL: They make me
very excited because I can--
MELANIE WARRICK: And
the previous week we
were even referencing
that, you know,
Hand Talk was looking
forward to ML Kit.
So, this is good.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, good timing.
Before we get stuck
into that, though,
we have our cool
things of the week.
And then at the end, we'll
have our question of the week.
We're going to talk
more about DevRel.
We're going talk about what is
a Developer Programs Engineer.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, we will.
As you mentioned,
Mark, we, as always,
like to start out with the
cool things of the week.
We actually wanted to note
that our 10th Doodle for Google
winner is "dynomite,"
as the blog says.
MARK MANDEL: Terrible pun.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
It's horrible.
Sarah Gomez-Lane apparently
drew a delightful dinosaur
that highlight her dream of
becoming a paleontologist.
So there's this
really cute image
that she did that's
got dinosaurs,
and I really kind of love it.
And I know Aja, who's
one of our teammates,
would love this as well.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
And what I love
about this, as well,
is that for the first time
in the Doodle for Google's
10-year history, the
winner has the opportunity
to actually turn
their submission
into an animated interactive
Doodle that will be featured
on the Google homepage.
So I, for one, am very
much looking forward
to seeing dinosaurs that are
hand-drawn on the homepage.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And apparently she's
got a nice chunk of
reward for the drawing
as well to go towards a
college scholarship, which
is wonderful.
So that's awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I think that's great.
One thing I wanted to
highlight as well, as everyone
in our audience is
aficionados of podcasts,
there is a new
Google podcast app
that you can grab on Android.
That's available for you
that you can go and download.
We'll have a link
in the show notes.
It has some nice integrations
with things like Google Home
and all the Google
fun stuff there.
And I just figured I'd
mention it because, of course,
you can now grab the
Google Cloud Platform
Podcast on there, as well.
And it has some nice
features about being
able to play in one place and
pick up where you left off
in others and stuff like that.
So, just let you know.
Podcast people would
like podcast things.
MELANIE WARRICK: Another
thing we wanted to mention
is that there was
another course that's
been released between
Google and Coursera
around machine learning.
We know there was a crash
course that we mentioned
a little while back, and
there's apparently a new course
out that's more for specializing
in machine learning,
with an emphasis on TensorFlow.
And so they have five specific
focuses in the courses
around like how Google
does machine learning,
and the specialization launching
into machine learning, what
TensorFlow is, feature
engineering, and the art
and science of machine learning.
And so yeah.
You can find that on Coursera.
MARK MANDEL: Fancy.
We have lots of new and
interesting things today.
So also introducing
Cloud Dataflow
has a new streaming engine,
which is super nice.
It basically has a bunch of
different and interesting and
useful performance
enhancements for how
to do streaming on Dataflow.
What's super-nice
about it is basically,
if you want to try it, there
is a new pipeline parameter.
You can --experiments=enable
streaming engine.
You don't have to change your
code or anything like that.
You can just
basically turn it on.
Eventually, once this
goes general availability
it'll literally just
switch on by default
and you'll just get new
good stuff, just because.
But if you want to give it a
go, make sure nothing breaks,
see if the fixes work for you--
give it a go now
and give it a shot.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And the blog that we
link to includes a
nice overview about how
to think about pricing as
well as where to get started.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
Absolutely.
MELANIE WARRICK: Last
thing we wanted to mention
is there's a blog post
by Barrett Williams, who
has written about how to
use the Cloud-to-Speech app,
as well as the
Text-to-Speech app.
And he does a nice
overview explanation
of how to implement these
tools and what to do with them.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's
like a really nice sort
of "hello world" of taking
speech, turning into text,
and taking text and
turning into speech.
He even touches on SSML in
here too, which we talked about
in a previous episode.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well,
Mark, I think it's time
that we go talk about ML Kit.
MARK MANDEL: Let's go do it.
So, recently at
Google I/O, I got
excited to see a new
product announcement
about ML Kit from Firebase.
And today, I'm pretty
excited to have both Sachin
Kotwani, product
manager for Firebase,
and Brahim "Elboukhini"--
[BUZZER SOUND]
No, it's "Elboushini."
Elbouchikhi.
There we go.
Brahim Elbouchikhi,
group product manager
for Android joining us today.
Yeah, I can't get names right.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
[LAUGHS] Sachin, how
are you doing today?
SACHIN KOTWANI: Doing great.
So glad to be here.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Brahim, how are you doing?
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI:
I'm doing great.
[LAUGHS]
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
Before we get stuck into ML
Kit, which I really want to do,
do you want to tell us a
little bit about who you are
and what you do?
Sachin, why don't you go first?
SACHIN KOTWANI: Sure.
So I've been at Google for
a little over eight years.
I've been a product
manager for most of those.
And I've been on the Google
Play team, where I first
got the chance to with Brahim.
I also worked on the
Cloud Platform team
on developer tools.
And over the past year, I've
been on the Firebase team
and I work on ML Kit.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And Brahim?
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI: Hey.
Yeah, so, I've been at Google
for almost seven years.
Starting off also on Google
Play and Android, then
moved on to do some
VR stuff at Daydream,
and then for past year
I've been leading the work
on machine learning on Android.
Now I spend a bunch of
my time with ML Kit,
as well other things
like the neural networks
API for hardware acceleration,
TensorFlow Lite, and such.
So, yeah-- lots of fun ML stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
Well, so what is ML Kit?
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI: OK.
So, ML Kit is essentially
Google's machine
learning SDK, available through
Firebase-- integrated deeply
into Firebase.
It offers a couple
of capabilities.
One is what we call Base APIs.
These are APIs that essentially
allow you to do stuff--
you get an input and
you get an output.
There is, essentially, as far
as the developer is concerned,
no machine learning involved.
Google provides the
machine learning models
and makes them available
through a simple API.
So that's one set of things.
And then the other
aspect is essentially
enabling developers to use
their own custom models
and making that as
easy as possible.
That is something that Sachin
is deeply familiar with,
so I'm going to maybe ask
you to jump in and talk
a bit about that, Sachin.
SACHIN KOTWANI: Sure.
Brahim, before I jump
into that, I actually
also want to talk about one
cool thing about Base APIs--
that I think it's a very
interesting and different
from what we've seen
thus far in this space--
is that ML Kit offers APIs that
run both on-device or in-cloud.
And depending on the
functionality you want to use,
some APIs are available
to run fully on-device.
Some are only
available in the cloud,
and some offer the option
of using one or the other.
And of course, if you want to
do something more powerful,
the capabilities will be
there in the cloud API,
but if you want to
do something locally,
you could do that on-device.
Now, for the custom models--
if you are an expert
in machine learning,
you know ML Kit first and
foremost positions itself
as a tool that makes
it very easy to bring
machine learning to your apps.
But if you're already
familiar with TensorFlow
and creating your
own models, you
can also use ML Kit to
deliver those models
to your developers.
And you would upload
your custom model
and it would be seamlessly
deployed to the user's device
without them having to
download anything manually.
So that infrastructure
piece is taken care of.
We are just getting
started there.
There's a lot more to
come in the near future,
but that's an area
that we are really
passionate about as well.
MARK MANDEL: Just so we're a
hundred percent clear as well,
I think you both said apps.
Are we talking about--
this is machine
learning for mobile devices?
Is that is that kind of
the market we're talking
about right here?
SACHIN KOTWANI: That's correct.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Cool.
So you said as well, there's
a bunch of built-in ML Kit
functionality that people
don't have to build themselves.
What is that functionality
that's available?
SACHIN KOTWANI: The ones
that are there right now,
out of the box, are text
extraction, face detection,
barcode recognition,
image labeling,
and landmark recognition.
Those are the ones that
are available today.
And as you-- you know, probably
recognize they are mostly
around vision, for now.
MELANIE WARRICK: In
terms of these APIs,
how would they
integrate with something
that's like, the APIs
in the GCP environment--
the Google Cloud
Platform environment?
SACHIN KOTWANI: That's
a great question.
So as I mentioned earlier,
these APIs or these use cases,
are available both
on-device and in-cloud.
The ones that are
available in-cloud
are run on top of that Google
Cloud Platform ML APIs.
So they're using,
you know, underlying
it all is the same APIs for
the cloud version of it.
MELANIE WARRICK: This
sounds really cool.
Brahim, maybe you
can talk to this
because you seem to be on
the Android side of things.
What were the needs that you
were seeing from customers
who wanted to be able
to do, like machine
learning on mobile devices.
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI:
Once we started
looking at this
some time ago, we
realized that one is the apps
are actually using machine
learning on-device, right?
This isn't something
that's entirely new.
We actually came across
a bunch of developers
who have been able to do this.
However, there were
a lot of challenges.
It was quite difficult, and that
was for a number of reasons.
One is building the
model itself and the fact
that you needed a
lot of training data
and then you needed a lot
of not only training data,
but also the ability to create
a mobile-optimized model.
That was quite challenging
for developers.
We met some developers that
had built their own runtimes
on-device just to
execute TensorFlow
models because at
the time, there
weren't any available runtimes
like TensorFlow Lite, which
we have right now.
So there were a
lot of challenges
when we looked out there that
made machine learning on apps
quite challenging and we wanted
to address a lot of those
initially.
So, for example,
we came across apps
that, from a use
case perspective,
that did like music learning,
and so basically you
have an instrument.
You're playing on
an analog guitar,
like a real actual
instrument, and the phone
is recording what you're
playing and trying to assess
how well you're playing.
Well, actually, a lot
of that is happening
through on-device
machine learning
models that are tuned
to echo cancellation,
to the environment you're
in, to the specific learning
patterns you have.
And then we talked to
specific developers
that do that, like
Yousician, for example.
It's an app that's
on Android and iOS.
We came across
apps that help you
manage what you eating, and
counting your calorie intake.
We came across fitness apps that
try to track your movements.
Or apps that allow you
to scan in content.
So, for example,
Evernote is using
machine learning to allow you to
take a picture of a whiteboard
and then it kind of
indexes what's in it,
and allow you to
search for it later on.
So one thing we quickly learned
is that this stuff is useful.
It's actually used
by a few developers,
but it's very challenging.
It's way too challenging
for it to become common use.
And so our goal was to-- and
we repeated this across kind
of launch of ML Kit--
was to kind of make
ML not so special.
Right now, machine learning
is like a special thing.
You needed lots of education.
You need a lot of background.
You need a lot of experience
in math and other things
like that to use it.
But we wanted to just be
actually just another toolkit
that a developer has
access to that they
can solve specific problems
with when they need them to.
And so that was kind of
the goal and the mission
behind ML Kit from day one.
So to summarize,
yeah, we looked at--
there were use cases for it.
It was used in practice, but
it was way too challenging.
And so we wanted to address
some of those things
with ML Kit features
that we have launched,
and some that we
are still launching
in the next few months.
MARK MANDEL: It sounds awesome.
I'm guessing I can probably
picture what this looks like.
And Sachin, maybe
you can talk to this.
So if I actually want to
use ML Kit as a developer,
I assume these are like
baked into the Firebase SDKs.
Is that how I would use them.
What does this look like?
SACHIN KOTWANI: That's correct.
So depending on what
capabilities you want to use,
they're modularized in
different Firebase SDKs.
But you know, just
with a couple of lines
in your build.gradle
or your Podfile,
you can get this
capability added.
I must confess here, you know,
when the team was building
ML Kit, I was really
looking forward
to the experience as a
developer-- as a hacker,
myself-- just to jump in
and start using the APIs.
And as I said, you
know just you just
add a few lines to
your build.gradle file,
depending on what
APIs you want to use.
And then once you have an
image, or a set of images,
you can start calling
those APIs on them.
And you can have a
prototype working.
You know, if it took me about
15 minutes to get working,
I would expect the average
listener of this podcast
to do it much faster.
As Brahim was saying, we
wanted to make ML not so
special, and very easy to use.
And that's what we aim
to do with ML Kit--
very simple to use APIs.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds great.
I know you also
mentioned that this
could be run both on the
phone as well as in the cloud.
Is there a difference in
capabilities between the two
offerings there, or
are they the same?
Brahim, I see you
nodding your head.
You want to answer
that question?
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI: Yeah.
Yeah, sure.
I mean, I think the
benefits of on-device--
there's always
trade-offs, obviously,
like everything else in life.
On-device, what you get
is the real-time aspect.
You don't need to upload a
ton of data to the cloud,
obviously, so it is--
it can be a [INAUDIBLE]
sensitive approach
to machine learning.
And also, it's actually
free of charge.
It runs on-device, and so the
API itself-- the use of the API
itself-- is free
to the developer.
So those are some big points.
But of course, you
also get limitations.
On the cloud, you
have the power of GCP.
You have the power of TPUs.
You have, essentially,
the ability
to run and execute
incredibly large models that
give you more.
So, for example, if you
look at our image labeling
API, which we have both a cloud
and an on-device variation
of it, the cloud variation
has over 10,000 labels,
meaning they can tell you about
10,000 things about this image
that you've submitted.
The on-device one
has little over 400.
So you can do-- what we've seen
developers do typically, is
do core classification
on-device,
where they essentially look
for interesting things.
So let's say I am trying
to classify an image
and want to make
sure that I only
do the cloud call
if I see that there
is some food in the image.
So maybe I will actually--
or maybe plants or flowers--
and so maybe I'll run
the on-device API,
see if I get any keywords
that I'm looking for,
like flower, or plant,
or something like that,
and if I do then I'm
like, oh, OK, I actually
want to know specifically
what kind of flower this is.
Then I'm going to call
the Google Cloud Platform
API to then get the more
fine-grained classification.
And so we do things,
these pairings.
We see developers do this
in a number of places,
and we actually
are also invested
in making sure these transitions
are even more seamless
and even in building use cases
and journeys or end-to-end
built to be what we call hybrid.
We have a bunch of exciting
stuff coming up there
in the future, but we see this
as an increasingly common use
case, of relying on both
cloud and on-device.
MELANIE WARRICK:
I mean I know you
mentioned that a lot of the APIs
are geared towards more visual.
What are some functionalities
that-- or APIs--
that you would like to see, or
you're seeing more of a need
for from the different
people that you work with?
SACHIN KOTWANI: You know
it's still early days,
so we're still trying
to gather that feedback
and see what the requests are.
But you can obviously
imagine that some
of the things that we're
starting to talk about
are speech, video--
you know, it follows
closely after image.
But, again, it's early days.
We would love to
hear from developers,
from the listeners
of the podcast,
if they have any
suggestions on what
they would like to see next.
For now, I'd also like to add--
and as Brahim said,
this is an area
that I'm passionate about--
that we do have the capabilities
for forecasting models.
So if there are any specific
capabilities that can be around
in TensorFlow Lite
models and developers
would like to use those.
They can deploy
them immediately.
They can upload their
TensorFlow Lite models to ML Kit
and start using them
for on-device inference.
And of course, there are
always the GCP capabilities
there for someone wants to run
a TensorFlow model in the cloud.
You can interact
with those, as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: Are
there any resources
you'd recommend,
especially around models
that maybe somebody has done--
custom models that
others have done
that are sharing them
and open-sourcing them?
SACHIN KOTWANI: Yeah,
that's a great question.
TensorFlow has a website called
TensorFlowHub, and that's
one of the things that they
do, is share snippets of code
or pre-bundled modules
that people can leverage
to create their own models.
And, you know, as for
completed models goes,
of course, the usual
suspects apply.
You can always look on GitHub or
Hackernews or any of, you know,
Medium posts.
There's a pretty
active community
out there building
TensorFlow models.
Now, I'd like to call out
that what ML Kit supports
is TensorFlow Lite models.
So you probably also want
to visit the TensorFlow Lite
website to see what
models are already
available in the
TensorFlow Lite format,
and how to go about converting
TensorFlow models TensorFlow
Lite.
MARK MANDEL: Just out
of curiosity as well,
I was reading that-- just
actually as we were sitting
here--
what's the difference
there between TensorFlow
and TensorFlow
Lite, just so people
have at least a broad
understanding of what
that difference is?
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI:
TensorFlow Lite is obviously
born out of TensorFlow.
It's essentially an
extension of TensorFlow.
It is built with mobile in mind.
And so effectively, the
runtime is much smaller.
It goes from over a meg
to about 200 kilobytes.
The storage uses flat buffers so
that the storage of the models
is far more efficient
and smaller.
And it also has a more
limited set of ops
that have been optimized
for mobile devices.
Over time, the team
is looking to expand
the number of operators and
also the number of capabilities
that it has beyond
just these operators,
but we're very much
taking, kind of,
start with what's
most needed on mobile,
and then expand from there.
TF Lite comes--
TensorFlow Lite comes
with a set of tools
that allow you to convert a
model from TensorFlow to be
TensorFlow Lite compatible.
That can also be
done in the cloud
through some of
ML Kit's services,
but it does come with an offline
tool that can do that as well.
And the team is continuing to
release a bunch of cool stuff.
So I'm really excited
about the roadmap,
too, around tools that
allow you to compress models
and, you know, things
like quantization
of models that allow you to
have vastly more efficient
mobile-centric models.
So lots-- lots and
lots happening there.
But yeah, it is essentially
an extension of TensorFlow,
and it was built from the
ground up with performance
and mobile in mind.
You know, I'm very
mobile-centric,
but the TensorFlow
Lite team actually is--
is they care a lot about
things, like you know,
it's available on Raspberry Pi.
It's available for-- and you
know, they're working on IOT.
They're working on kind of
tiny, tiny little sensors
that can run the models.
TensorFlow Lite is
kind of TensorFlow
beyond kind of server side.
And so they cover a ton
of different platforms,
and they're pretty versatile.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And just so I'm a
hundred percent clear,
as well, TensorFlow Lite models
can only be run on-device,
or can it be both
on-device and in the cloud?
SACHIN KOTWANI: That's
a great question.
I don't know if anyone's ever--
you know, we've never tried
running a TensorFlow Lite
model in the cloud.
MARK MANDEL: I have no idea
about machine learning,
so I just ask silly questions.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, you
could run it in the cloud.
It's a computer.
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI:
You just wouldn't do it
because you know
the point of it is
that it is far more limited--
SACHIN KOTWANI: Yeah.
You mean, you know,
you just wouldn't.
MARK MANDEL: I guess my point
is, you would build this
specifically for
running on-device
and that's its purpose,
so you would do that.
OK.
Got it.
SACHIN KOTWANI: Absolutely.
It's-- yes, it's
optimized for mobile,
and that's what you
would use it for.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, great.
What other things have we
not covered around, you know,
ML Kit and how useful
it is for those
who are working on
Android or working in IOT
or looking at devices?
What are some of the
other tips and tricks
that you'd recommend?
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI: I
have a couple of things
that I think are
quite important.
One is that ML Kit
is cross-platform,
so it's actually
iOS and Android.
And this was really
important for us--
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI: --as someone
who was on the Android team,
you know one of the first
things I asked my execs for
is like, hey-- we're going
to need iOS engineers.
And that's because when
we talked to developers,
they think of machine
learning as a thing.
They don't think
of Android machine
learning and iOS
machine learning.
And so it was very
important that we
offer a cross-platform
solution, and we
think that is actually one
of the most compelling,
in addition to our
[INAUDIBLE] capabilities,
so that's a very unique
differentiator of ML Kit
that we're excited about.
That's number one.
The other aspect I
wanted to highlight
is the fact that when we talk
about making ML Kit not so
special, one of the key
things about that was that--
hey, there are a bunch of like,
traditional mobile challenges
that developers care about.
Things like binary
size, and A/B testing,
and all this other stuff
that had been essentially,
you know, not impossible
but really hard for ML.
So today, if let's say, you
wanted to A/B test two models,
you really had to bundle two
potentially 10 meg models each,
and then you'd be
stuck with them.
You bundle them to the
APK, you'll ship the APK,
you'll do some offline
tests, and then you're
stuck with those two
models for the duration
of your experiments.
You cannot really iterate any
faster than your APK release.
And developers have
been trying to solve
these problems for a long time.
And they've been
solved for mobile--
those many, many platforms,
most notably Firebase, which
has things like remote config
and A/B testing and Google
Analytics.
And so we wanted
to bring and solve
some of these like,
just mobile challenges
for machine learning.
And so a lot of the custom
model stuff that we've built
is around model deployment--
out-of-band of an APK update,
or using a remote config
to actually name the model
and then retrieve the
right model based on what
experiment group you're in.
So we made, essentially,
experimenting with ML models
literally a one-line
change in your app.
And that's something
that, you know,
Sachin is really,
really invested in
and pushing the envelope further
and further in that direction.
But I just wanted
to reiterate that is
when we said we
want ML to be not so
special, we weren't just solving
machine learning problems.
We weren't just thinking
about how to build
the best and greatest models.
We were also
thinking about, hey,
like, how do we solve stuff
that developers just care
about, like APK size, and so--
I don't know.
Sachin, you want to dig
into the compression stuff
from an APK size perspective?
SACHIN KOTWANI: Yeah.
So you know, one of
the things that I
want to reiterate that
Brahim was saying first was--
ML Kit doesn't exist in
isolation within Firebase,
right?
There is a reason
why it's there.
It's because Firebase offers an
additional very, very broad set
of tools that are useful.
And services that are useful
for mobile developers--
remote config, analytics,
and A/B testing
are just a few examples.
Within the ML Kit
family itself, model
compression and conversion
at specific use case
for TensorFlow models.
So let's say you want to
do image classification
and you have a model
that you have invested
a lot of time and effort in.
Perhaps you have a
research team that
optimizes them to make
them work really well
and to increase the precision.
And now you want to get
it working on mobile.
We have functionality that would
convert to TensorFlow Lite not
only converted from TensorFlow
to TensorFlow Lite, right,
but also compress
it to make sure
that it runs efficiently and
doesn't take too much storage
space on the device.
So that's one area that we
are still actively working on.
We are testing it with a
few partners right now.
We talked about Fishbrain
in other forums as well.
They took models that were
several hundred megs in size
and reduced them
by a factor of 10
without losing much
precision at all.
And actually, I think in
their particular case,
we were able to even
increase it, which is great.
So that's about
compression and conversion.
Another area that I'm really
excited about-- and you folks
asked about typical
use cases, you know,
that our developers
and our early partners
would use ML Kit for.
One area that I'm
really excited about
is about what developers come
up with because machine learning
is such a different paradigm
from any other software
development.
You know, you can
download a library.
You can add some UI.
You can change a
database, right?
Those are common concepts that
are great and still important--
very much alive.
But machine learning is so
different from any of that,
and it can provide such
different capabilities.
So that's one area
that I'm really
excited about is to see what
new things developers build
when it comes to these tools.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Actually, just one thing
I want to make
sure I'm clear on.
When you're talking
about ML Kit and running,
especially custom
models, all of this
is from the inference side.
Is ML Kit also geared to help
people do training of models?
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI: The short
answer is, not at the moment.
There are lots of investments
around on-device learning.
That's one area-- the one
area that we're looking at.
There are things on Federated
Learning where it's--
Google published a paper on
that about a year or two ago.
For those who are curious,
a super, super cool paper to
read.
But, yeah-- nothing
in the immediate--
currently that allows us
to help with training.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That is something
you guys have in your mind as
what you're looking at, yeah?
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI: It's
absolutely in our mind,
and we know that Google Cloud is
making investments in that area
as well through
auto-ML and others.
And so we're definitely
working across Google
to make that a
reality on ML Kit.
MARK MANDEL: I've got to
ask the tough question.
This sounds great for mobile,
but Firebase supports the web.
Are we going to get some
JavaScript APIs for some
of this stuff anytime soon?
[LAUGHING]
SACHIN KOTWANI: Of course,
the tough question goes to me.
That's a great question.
And I want to get that
question more and more
because the more we
get that question,
the more it means that we should
be working in that aspect.
So, for now, as I said, it
works on Android and iOS.
We are hearing from
a few developers
that they would like
to see it in mobile
and I want to, as I
said, keep hearing that.
For now, if anyone wants to do
machine learning on the web,
I would point them
to TensorFlow.js.
There are obviously
a lot of models
that are open-source and
available and ready to use
in TensorFlow format, so
that's one way to go for now.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Anything that you want
to talk about that's
potentially exciting on
the roadmap for ML Kit
that people should
keep an eye out for?
SACHIN KOTWANI: Oh, man.
There are so many
exciting things.
And I don't know if I can
talk about any of them.
Brahim is looking at
me like, do not say.
[LAUGHING]
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI: No, I mean--
I think some of the stuff that--
one is obviously reiterating
that what we have in the market
now.
It's things like
image labeling APIs
is sometimes mind-boggling.
You have an API that on-device
you give it an image,
it tells you what's in it.
That is super cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely.
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI:
We also are super
excited about the new face
contour API in a beta right
now.
We're testing with
a few developers.
So that's going to be super
cool and if you see it--
you saw a demo of
Sachin doing this
at I/O. It's now a legendary
get food in the team.
MARK MANDEL: Hmm.
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI: So that's
going to be super exciting.
And just look for
us to keep pushing.
You know the promise we made
to developers, quite publicly
at I/O, is that we will be
knocking on Google Research's
doors and asking them to
bring their capabilities
to developers in the
nice-to-use, easy-to-use
packaging, and we're continuing
to do that behind the scenes.
We're continuing to push
for making Google's best
machine learning technologies
available through ML Kit
and that's the-- that's a
generic promise we're making.
In terms of specifics,
I think we'll
have to leave it at
what's coming now
as a white list, and
all that good stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well,
thank you both again
for coming on the podcast
to talk to us about ML Kit.
Just any additional
last-minute plugs or things
you're speaking at?
A research that you want
to let people know about?
SACHIN KOTWANI: Yeah.
You know, I would just
really encourage everyone
to give ML Kit a try.
You know, at least from
the experience, and the fun
part of it and just getting
up and running really quick
and seeing results.
It's a very, very
rewarding experience.
So I'd love for all
of you to try it out
and to let us know
what you think
and what you would
like to see next year.
We have quite a lot of
things that we have in mind
that we want to work
on and deliver soon,
but we also look forward
to hearing from all of you
to learn what things
you'd like to see next.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Well, thank you to
both of you for coming
and hanging out with us today.
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI: All right.
Well, just to close--
you know, not to date this
podcast, but it is a World Cup,
and go, Morocco.
We're going to beat Spain--
Sachin's team--
sometime next week.
So be on the lookout for that.
Go Morocco.
SACHIN KOTWANI: We'll see.
We'll see.
Vamos España.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
Thank you, guys.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
BRAHIM ELBOUCHIKHI: Thanks.
All right.
Bye.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thanks
again Brahim and Sachin
for coming on the podcast to
talk with us about ML Kit.
It was good to get that
overview and understand
what these tools are, what the
tool is, and how to use it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
MELANIE WARRICK: So, Mark--
MARK MANDEL: Yes?
MELANIE WARRICK: What is a
developer programs engineer?
MARK MANDEL: Well, I'm not
going to try and explain this
because I'm a
developer advocate.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
you don't know anything
about that as a
developer advocate?
MARK MANDEL: Well, no.
I was going to say I
would develop an advocate.
Develop a program engineer--
at least in Google Cloud,
sit-in the same
organization as we do.
So we have developer relations.
You want to go listen to
the episode with Mandy.
I definitely do.
And so DPEs, or a
Developer Program Engineer,
sit next to us.
We're peers, I think,
is a nice way to put it.
MELANIE WARRICK: We hang out.
MARK MANDEL: And
there's a really great--
we hang out.
We totally hang out.
We all sit together,
which is lovely.
And I'm going to hope I don't
absolutely massacre her name.
There's a great article
from Franziska Hinkelmann,
who is the DPE at
Google Cloud Platform.
Apparently talking and doing
a lot of Node.js stuff,
and they write a
really great article
about-- basically, they
explain how they're
engineers in
developer relations,
and they sit at the
intersection of developer
advocacy, technical
writing, product
management, and engineering.
And so they do a
very similar role,
I feel, to what we do--
is to offer advocates
with interacting
with the community,
but they definitely do it
in a very interesting way.
I feel like personally from my
perspective from the outside,
they do it from almost
a very code perspective,
which I think is really cool.
And they definitely do
some really cool things.
It's well worth the read.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
And we did a podcast on data
science a few weeks back,
and Michelle Casper who
was on the podcast--
actually she's a DPE, so--
I agree.
They have a nice intersection
into the DevRel space.
I'd agree.
It's a good read.
Mark, where are you going to be?
Where are you this week?
MARK MANDEL: Where
am I this week?
So I mentioned previously that
I am going to be in Denmark.
So last week on the podcast,
if you were all listening--
and I'm sure you were--
we mentioned, very briefly,
the Unity announcement.
So we announced that
there's a strategic alliance
between Unity and
Google Cloud Platform
now, which I'm
particularly excited about,
working in the game space.
So definitely stay tuned
to what's happening there.
There's a lot of really
cool stuff going on there.
So, basically, what
I'm doing this week is,
I'm actually going up to
Denmark to participate
in Unity's internal Hackweek.
So they have a
week-long R&D week away.
I feel like it's
like summer camp.
I kind feel like I'm
going to summer camp.
I'm going to go meet a
whole bunch of new people
that I've never met
before, but once I leave,
I'm going to be
friends with everybody.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Aw, that sounds fun.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Kind of that's it, but
it's a big R&D week,
so I'm going to go down
there and hang out with them
and hack on a bunch of stuff.
It's going to be really fun.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, good.
And then come back and
you'll have jet lag.
MARK MANDEL: I'll have jet lag.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Which will be lovely.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
What are you up to?
MELANIE WARRICK: Great question.
So this week, and
specifically tomorrow,
I'm going to be speaking
to a group of students who
are participating in AI4ALL.
And AI4ALL is a
nonprofit working
to increase diversity
and inclusion
in artificial intelligence.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: This is
based out of Stanford.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: So, yeah.
That will be tomorrow.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right.
Oh, we should make
a mention that we'll
both be at Cloud Next.
We should probably
talk about that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah,
Next is coming up.
I haven't even checked,
but tickets are still
on sale I think.
Let's find out.
Yes.
You should come
and check it out.
July 24 through 26.
Tickets are on sale now.
We can include that
link in the show notes.
But, yeah, we'll be at Next.
We'll be interviewing a
bunch of people at Next.
So, if you are going to be
there, come by and say hi.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely
come by and say hi.
I will be there.
I'm speaking about
[INAUDIBLE] which
will be lots and lots of fun.
But, yeah, we'll be
doing daily episodes
as well while we're at Next,
so expect lots of good content.
And if you're there,
maybe swing past--
see if there is a little
slot for you to come hang out
and do a little quick interview.
MELANIE WARRICK: We may also
have a few things to give out,
so you should definitely
come check us out.
MARK MANDEL: Mm.
That's true.
That is true.
MELANIE WARRICK: Mark, I think
that's it for us for this week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so thanks again
for joining me for another
week on the podcast Melanie.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you all for listening,
and we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]